hot breath do you now have like another
hour like how quickly do you turn over
material
yeah i'm not i mean i've seen the other
guys do it
they're doing it faster than i am i i
need a little bit more
like that louis was doing it louie and
burr like they were doing once a year
like every year and that's
to me is i can't do it that far yeah i
mean that's yeah though it's in 2018
2018 and uh i don't know i was on a
pretty good pace
turning it over i'm not sure really
where i was
my mindset is i'd rather be over
prepared so if
it takes a a few years i'd rather be
over prepared
than than the the material for me
getting halfway there and being like
okay i'm gonna put this out i'd rather
be over prepared for it so
i'd rather have an hour 20 and i'd be
forced to cut
it to an hour versus you know not
straining to get that hour or the things
not being tight enough
because we can all tell the level of
laughs that we're getting in the
audience it's like oh that's getting
some kind of a laugh
but it's not getting the deep gut laugh
that i need
so it's like it could be funnier or if
it's getting that kind of a laugh maybe
that's a jab
into something stronger you know i can't
just
leave that i can't just leave that at
that level
of laughter it's not it's not usable
for me unless it's to get into something
else that's much funnier